- The Supreme court
just heard oral argument
in an incredibly interesting
First Amendment case related
to students.
You might not know this,
but students do have
First Amendment rights.
After all public schools
are an arm of the government
so if they punish you for your speech,
even if you are a minor student,
then that might be a violation
of the First Amendment,
and this is an incredible
case where a student
said some curse words on
social media, on Snapchat,
and this was outside of school,
but someone brought that
into the school and then
the school punished her
for saying these curse words,
and so, the question is
where does the right of the students end?
Can they be punished in school
for something they did outside of school?
It's going to be
an incredibly interesting
First Amendment case
and we'll see where the lines are drawn
with respect to student rights,
and so we'll see you in court.